ce soir c'est l'anniversaire d'un fan 12
à aa ils nous regardent
mais il n'est pas du tout au courant
qu'on va l'appeler tout de suite pour
lui souhaiter
et ouais sauf à 12 on l'appelle tout de
suite vous allez voir c'est une petite
surprise qu'on lui fait on va l'appeler
pour lui souhaiter un bon anniversaire
est ce qu'on peut appeler tout de suite
la personne s'il vous plaît on est en
train il fallait l'appeler un petit peu
avant sont en train de faire le numéro
on est en direct vous connaissez la
régie tnp alors on le numéro on le fait
à comment crédit colle ça sonne à l'eau
etienne oui ça va mon chéri sam à vos
souris
si tu veux pas me parler je veux tu me
le dis franchement j'ai d'autres amis
j'ai d'autres fans 12 etienne etienne
total téléphone tient le bien
[Rires]
mais y aller c'est le talent non mais tu
peux pas comprendre une section de dieu
il inquiète pas ce que je vous ai vu toi
sont donc c'est pas la panique
balancerait etienne a on le rappelle
deuxième chance etienne au bout de 3 5
mais malheureusement on t'appellera plus
merci en tout cas de voix que c'est bien
qu'à lire franchement c'est quoi c'est
comme on aime c'est une belle c'est quoi
aller les chaînes on pouvait voir une
très grosse surprise c'est parti merci
merci à la régie à l'eau et y est oui
étienne frère tu es sorti à la fenêtre
pour par kelly kelly brook etienne
etienne sa basse et cyril c'est papa
frérot suis sortie oui oui moi à mon
chéri je voulais te souhaiter un bon
anniversaire
oui tu fais ton anniversaire chez toi là
tu es tranquille et demain sur cd
projekt à 9
c'est donc j'ai découvert que mon cou
[Musique]
l'émission oui honnêtement on était
devant et ne peux pas le voir nous
etienne à étienne tu veux pas et tu peux
pas les ouvrir la porte de chez toi on
va voir on veut la part de chez toi
etienne etienne je peux oui bah babel ou
10 mois attend 400 m² sur la vie de ma
mère il nommerait l'a pas faire moi
quand je vois la porte du vous l'a
toutefois alors tu as ouvert la porte ou
pas
pedro était ouvert et alors qu'est ce
que tu vois belles voix du monde cariou
bah ouais parce que je t'explique ce
soir ça va être le feu on va faire une
très grosse soirée chez toi non
il ya 400 personnes via russie
c'est un rêve de malades wave au shérif
est ce qu'on peut voir parce qu'on voit
rien du tout là ça va être l attaque ta
meuf mais town
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si toi
mentionnez de couteau
[Applaudissements]
entre elles empruntent une fente à tous
oui et yann ça maintenant
hélas
[Applaudissements]
m
etienne ça va rentrer encore un sale
entre encore etienne etienne c'est le
soldat qui regardent la télé torse nu en
chine
j'ai jamais vue à l'âge de ma vie quoi
bon faire superbe
[Musique]
je pense
à la fin
[Musique]
on risque d'avoir un put my attend le
début une fête entre elles à la syrie on
vous entend plus du tout en faire alors
ça sert mais un passant ma chérie je
voulais dire etienne y est on va lui
offrir un séjour au ski parce que c'est
son rêve d'aller au ski je t'offre un
séjour pour 4 personnes dans un
appartement n'ouvre la porte en france
au ski
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau y aura de la
neige roi de la pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci mon rabat
[Musique]
courtois a reçu à l'agonie et c'est le
seul gars aussi les tiennent il croit
que c'est la stylée qui le filme et
regarde la télé et les commandes
elle m'a dit non c'est la caméra l'at-il
s2 film confié aux cadeaux et tient des
couteaux des côtes en effet besoin
bon apparemment les photos est grave
c'est vrai et c'est l'anniversaire de
ludivine le dividende anniversaire aussi
à remercier monsieur je veux juste dire
à tous les vents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et plus
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore voilà
pour accueillir afin de jouir
[Applaudissements]
le cerveau
l'habitat tiers vue-là c'est là c'est la
folie
à papa
si on va laisser faire la teinte et
bravo tiens et d'applaudissements quand
polluants
[Applaudissements]